ladies don't give it up for moms cancers
it's good to be here with my homies I
love doing stand-up comedy it's one of
my favorite things but it can be a
little harsh at times you know sometimes
I wish I was a painter because I've
never been painting a picture and how
the canvas be like like a tree you
should quit
Asian nose painting
my name is pons cam I think that
deserves some explanation it's not a
stage name I was like how do I get
audiences to think about North Korea and
the Nazis when comedy my parents gave me
hugs because they don't want kids in
school to make fun of me from having an
Asian name so they gave me a German what
instead
so just the fact and it worked like a
charm
they had no idea I was Asian a lot of
heart being the only Asian in school
full of white people like my friends
would say things like ohand
because such an Asian smile looks really
good like oh thanks man
now I get to think about how I'm
physically different from everyone
around me every time I feel happiness
the rest of my life the guy who told me
that was this white kid named tanner I
was like what Tanner Tanner than what
that's not a white person's name we
should be like hey this is my Mexican
friend Tanner
thanks not raising this is nothing
my friend Tanner went on a mission trip
if you don't know if that is a mission
trip is what Americans go to third world
countries to get new profile pictures
Hernan had a good photo shoot I'm single
I have yet to find my soul mate I
figured to think maybe it's her fault
she needs to get out more loser
I think dating is very interesting I
think it's fascinating that there are
two totally different types of people
both words the same species you know
like there's people that I would never
have sex with and there are people that
I can never have sex with
my friends like dude at least one not
gay 4k that means most of the gender
that were attracted to would be
attracted to us back and I was like whoa
can't even imagine
I love women I think they got the best
genitals in the human race at that point
in the top two
I want that women have sex with men
because I don't understand that I would
never do that
you know I've never looked at a
beautiful woman I thought yeah she's
great but is there a version of her
that's bigger and hairier and there's
less kindness that women give birth and
then down I feel like it that gave birth
baby lie bro I'm gonna do so much
protein and creatine during my pregnancy
its babies like 17 pounds already
check out this body sense of the
ultrasound this one girl I knew she was
talking about her vagina she was like my
vagina is a 3d printer haha I was like
that's not even accurate you know your
womb is a 3d printer your vagina is the
tray
schematically
it's not even a very good 3d printer
only printing one thing with lots of
errors take nine months to bring the
whole time it's printing is complaining
I talking to girls my friends are like
pawns used to learn how to talk to girls
like maybe you know maybe girls gonna
learn how to listen to Hans what you
want to hear about the FCC yeah that's a
real thing I don't understand the
censorship laws on TV because you can
get on TV and say [ __ ] and disrespect
women but you can't get on TV SH [ __ ]
and disrespect poop
I think women deserve the same
protection that we give to poop
this is a more purple word if we looking
down the street if someone's like you
drop something [ __ ] I'll be very
offended but if someone's like hey you
dropped your [ __ ] and they're like wow
what a considerate gangster another
silly rule on TV that you can show press
and I like to do is cover the nipple
which i think is ineffective but doing
it because if I see a woman white nipple
Pacey's that's so very sexy and I can
still masturbate to that if I had to the
science okay but if I see a woman
wearing a burqa that has holes of the
nipple should be I can not masturbate to
that
so as you're gonna come pretty lonely I
don't like carpool lanes I feel like
carpool lanes like society saying hey
you know higher though me yeah do it the
longer now think about it watch people
with friends whizzing by you